the dance of dragons a true telling by
grand mr munchen
being a history of the war of targaryen
succession between the princess frienera
and aegon
second of his name that nearly destroyed
the realm
the dance of the dragons a stupid name
for a targaryen civil war where my
ancestors
danced away my birthright before the war
house targaryen counted 18 dragons
by the end we had two and nearly as few
targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again the dance began
as many dancers do with an old man and a
young girl
the queen had failed to produce a son
for her king so he anointed his daughter
the princess rhaenyra
as his heir but years later the king
remarried
and his new wife queen alicent of house
hightower
gave him a son feeble and foolish the
old king refused to change the
succession
he didn't even see how his court had
split into two rival camps of blacks and
greens
after the dresses of the princess and
the queen had worn to some tawny
[Music]
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep
and ran to inform queen alicent protocol
dictated that the bells would be rung
and a raven sent to dragonstone to
summon the air princess rhaenyra for her
coronation
but alison had other plans
once she saw her dead husband's body she
sealed the room and had the servant
thrown into the black cells to ensure
his silence
at the hour of the owl the lord
commander of the kingsguard sir
christian cole
summoned the small council to inform
them of the king's death
sir otto hightower the hand of the king
and father to queen alicent
demanded that the succession be settled
immediately
the decrepit old men of the small
council were confused
the succession was settled in their
minds the old king had forced the lords
of westeros to swear fealty to princess
rhaenyra as his heir
but sir kristen cole rightly pointed out
that a son
comes before a daughter
the council argued until dawn when the
master of coin finally stood up and
declared he would have no part of
treason
so kristen cole wisely opened his throat
with a dagger
ending the debate none were more
surprised to hear of prince aegon's
succession than prince aegon himself
at first the fool rejected the crown but
his mother pointed out that his sister
rhaenyra would return such loyalty by
taking his head
as the old king's true born son he'd
always be a threat
aegon relented he was crowned in the
dragon pit
and his wife and sister helena became
queen his brother aymond flew off to win
over the few
great lords who support aegon didn't
already have the banner of the gold
dragon
flew over king's landing and the red
keep as aegon second of his name
ascended the iron throne
he would not sit it long when ravens
carried the news of aegon's coronation
to dragonstone
princess rhaenyra summoned her own black
council
with her was her uncle and husband damon
targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in westeros
few lords supported her but the greatest
of these was corliss valerian
who controlled the largest fleet in the
realm and his targaryen wife rhaenys
the old king's sister then there were
her five sons although
none grown to manhood a pitiful assembly
really
combined they couldn't match the power
of house hightower alone
but rhaenyra had dragons
she damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts
and three of her five sons were riders
as well
dragonstone also housed six more dragons
without riders
against this king aegon had only four
dragons of his own
dragons can burn a city but only armies
can take and hold it
if she was to prevail rhaenyra
desperately needed the support of the
few great houses not already sworn to
aegon
her eldest son jacaris flew to the vale
in the north
her middle son lucerus flew to the
stormlands rhaenyra hoped
that the war would begin and if the gods
were good
end with diplomacy
as always they weren't
little prince lucerus must have wet
himself when he entered storm's end and
found
king aegon's younger brother eamond
already with lord baratheon
eamonn was fearsome even before he lost
his eye and set a sapphire in its stead
but the princeling pleaded his mother's
case
finally lord baratheon made his decision
go on pup
and tell the [ __ ] your mother that the
lord of storm's end is not a dog she can
whistle up
as haman's false eye gleamed at him the
princeling fled the castle and mounted
his young dragon arax
the rain fell in sheets and great bolts
of lightning lit the world bright as day
arrax were struggling to stay aloft in
the gale
when a roar shook the very foundations
of storm's end
eamonn rose through the clouds and below
him
the monstrous veigar veigar was
five times the size of arax and the
hardened survivor
of a hundred battles vega caught him
above shipbreaker bay
watchers on the castle wall saw distant
blasts of flame
and heard a shriek drown out the thunder
prince loucarist fell broken to be
swallowed by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of fire and blood began
when rhaenyra heard of her son's death
she collapsed
she considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
damon
her son would be avenged
whispers slithered through the taverns
and back alleys of flea bottom
two men were found one was a former gold
cloak
the other a rat catcher in the red keep
who knew
all its secrets history remembers them
only
as blood and cheese one night
queen helena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed
without warning blood and cheese
bursting
daggers in hand they told her that a
debt was owed
a son for a son blood and cheese
demanded she choose which son would be
ripped from her forever
queen helena pleaded with the men to
kill her instead but they refused
weeping helena named her younger son
melo perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
perhaps because the older boy was king
aegon's
firstborn son and heir
you hear that little boy she's whispered
to the younger son
your mama wants you dead then blood
struck off the older boy's head with a
single blow
when the guards burst in they found
queen helena still
screaming clasping her dead son's body
to her
mad with grief the blood of their
children transformed a dynastic dispute
into a war of annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn
down the world either aegon
or rhaenyra could live at the end but
not both
rhaenyra's forces struck yet another
blow the moment the lord of harrenhal
saw damon targaryen
circling the castle on his dragon
correxes he struck his banners
and surrendered the blacks now had the
strongest castle in the riverlands
darker new still came to aegon thanks to
rhaenyra's sons
winterfell had declared for rhaenyra as
had the veil
furious aegon dismissed his grandfather
sir otto his hand
and appointed sir kristen cole who swore
to march on all the lords who had
declared for rhaenyra
and put their castles to the torch cole
and the royal army first marched north
and laid siege to rook's rest a black
stronghold near dragonstone
when their lord saw their approach he
sent a raven to rhaenyra
begging for help for days he watched his
fields and villages burning
with no response from his queen until
one day
a shadow passed over the green army
rhaenyra had sent not an army but her
former mother-by-law
rhaenys and her dragon melees as her
ancestor had done at the field of fire
rhaenys gleefully began to incinerate
sir kristen's army
but aegon had set a trap and rhaenys had
flown right into it
as rhaenys and melees blanketed sir
christian's troops and dragonflame
two other dragons rose into the sky
aymond on vegar
and king aegon himself on the gleaming
sun fire
to her credit rainey didn't flee
dragon fought dragons and his second son
blossomed in the sky when the smoke
cleared
only aymond and vegar stood uninjured
sunfire the most
magnificent dragon in the world had one
of its wings almost completely torn from
its body
trapped beneath sunfire was the king
himself broken and burned so badly in
places that his armor had fused onto his
flesh
his body survived but his mind was given
over to milk of the poppy
maylies had been torn to shreds and her
rider rhaenys
was a pile of ash
panicked by the defeat rhaenyra shipped
her two youngest sons across the narrow
sea for their protection only for her
youngest to return days later
clinging to the neck of his wounded and
dying dragon
he and his brother had been set upon by
an enemy fleet just off dragonstone
defying his mother's command rhaenyra's
eldest son and heir jaekerus
mounted his dragon vermax and flew to
rescue his other brother and punished
the enemy fleet
but the foolish boy let vermax be hooked
like a trout
and dragged into the sea where he soaked
up even more
arrows than seawater his brother
disappeared
over the horizon or beneath the waves no
one could say for sure
with the loss of four dragons rhaenyra's
only advantage was fading
luckily for her over the centuries house
targaryen had spilled more than blood on
dragonstone
she promised golden title to any of the
targaryen bastards who could tame the
six
unclaimed dragons on the island these
bastards were called the dragon seeds
though most were called supper and
perhaps the dragons were eventually
seated
or bored but four of them accepted
riders and were enlisted in rhaenyra's
cause
after rook's rest aim and one eye took
command of the greens from his crippled
and poppy adult brother
eamon was the blood of the dragon and
dragons don't cower behind city walls
he marched the king's army north to take
back harrenhal from rhaenyra's husband
damon but when he and kristen cole
reached the castle
they found the gates open with damon and
all his men
gone that night they feasted their
victory
damon had fled rather than face their
wrath
the damon was more snake than dragon as
eamonn
marched north he'd flown keraxis south
slithering past the green army over the
waters of the god's eye
one day king's landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul
city damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne
for the city was defenseless eamonn had
taken the king's army from the city
and worse he'd taken his dragon vaga
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small council surrendered the city the
queen mother alicent
and the broken queen helena but not king
aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city and so
queen rhaenyra climbed the steps and
seated herself on the iron throne
legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hens
proving the iron throne had spurned her
nonsense it's a chair made of steel
blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
had sacrificed two sons for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight
when aymond realized that his arrogance
had cost him the capital
he mounted vagar in a black rage and
rained fire onto every village and
castle he suspected of disloyalty
abandoned by eamonn sir kristen marched
the royal army back to king's landing
intent on recapturing the city himself
instead
he was trapped and cut to pieces by the
riverlords who had sworn to support
rhaenyra's claim
when a new army of green loyalists
marched up from the reach
and laid siege to the city of tumbleton
rhaenyra sent two of her dragon siege to
lay waste to them
instead the dragon seeds proved their
bastard nature
and betrayed her they burned the city
and all the black forces garrisoned
within
lucky for her they didn't turn towards
king's landing but
hauled and drank in the ruins with the
greens who were victorious
and somewhat confused
rainier now mistrusted all the dragon
seeds
including the girl who rode with her
husband damon hunting aymond in the
riverlands
she ordered the girl's head be sent to
her
but there was a complication
as well as her dragon the girl had taken
to riding demon
when damon received the queen's order he
proclaimed the queen's words and a
[ __ ] work
he sent the girl away at dawn watching
her and her dragon vanish into the
morning mists
then damon sent the challenge to his
nephew eamonn and flew to harrenhal
alone to wait
fourteen days later a shadow blacker
than any passing cloud
swept over harrenhal veigar had come
at last and on her back rode one-eyed
prince aymond
he mocked damon for facing him alone you
have lived too long
uncle and damon replied on that much
we agree then the old prince climbed
stiffly onto the back of his dragon
karaxis
but neglected to fasten the chains that
secured ryder to sun
the sun was close to setting when as one
the two dragons leapt into the sky
damon took karaxis up swiftly until they
disappeared into a bank of clouds
vegar older and slower and ascended more
gradually
up and up vegar sword searching for
karazzi's
sudden as a thunderbolt a shrieking
caraxes dove upon vegard
locked together the dragon stumbled
toward the lake
karaxi's jaws closed about vegar's neck
but vega rigged open kerax's belly and
her teeth
ripped off a wing the lake rushed up
with terrible speed
then daemon targaryen who had never
fastened his riding chains
stood in his saddle he leapt from his
dragon to aemons
and in his hand was dark sister the
valyrian sword of aegon's sister queen
visenya
as eamonn one eye looked up in terror
daemon ripped off his nephew's helm
and drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye
so hard the point came out the back of
the young
prince's throat half a heartbeat later
the dragons struck the lake sending up a
gout of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as
harrenhal's great
tower the lake boiled with dragon blood
and then was still daemon targaryen was
9 and 40 at his death
prince aymond had only turned 20.
vegar the greatest of the targaryen
dragons
had counted 181 years
thus passed the last living creature
from the days of aegon's conquest
back in king's landing queen rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her
stupid husband
the mad former queen helena flung
herself from a balcony to be impaled
upon the iron spikes lining the moat of
maegor's holdfast
that night the city rose in riot against
reiner demanding justice for queen
helena and her murdered son
among other foolish peasant fantasies
in the midst of this chaos a one-handed
fool called the shepherd began to
rant against dragons not just the ones
of the enemy
but all dragons everywhere as he pointed
to the dragonpit above on the hill he
shouted
there the demons dwell this is their
city if you would make it yours
first you must destroy them the cry went
up from ten thousand
throats kill them there were four
dragons housed within the dragon pit
that night
by the time the first of the attackers
came pouring in all four were roused
awake and angry nobody knows how many
men and women died that night
who cares they all should have trapped
within the pit
the dragons could not fly instead they
fought with horns
claws teeth and fire for every man who
died
ten more appeared shouting that the
dragons must die
one by one they did finally the last
remaining dragon
broke her chain spread her wings and
flew straight up at the great dome
trying to flee
already weakened by dragonflame the dome
cracked under the force of impact
and then tumbled down crushing dragon
slayers
and herself high atop
the red keep queen rhaenyra clutched her
two remaining sons to her as she watched
the end of her family's might
too afraid of the peasants to defend her
dragons
at least her older son joffrey had a
man's spine
he stole his mother's dragon cyrax and
tried to fly it to the dragon pit to
save his birthright
but the stupid beast didn't understand
and twisted beneath him fighting to be
free of the little boy
until it was a queen
is still a woman with all the weakness
of that sex
weeping for her lost son more than her
dragons
rhaenyra abandoned the iron throne and
sold her crown to buy passage for her
and her last
son back to dragonstone rhaenyra hoped
to hatch more dragons from the eggs in
the castle
but when she landed the welcoming party
slew her guards
and marched her and her son at spear
point to the castle
to face a dead man and a dying dragon
sister king aegon second of his name
called out to rhaenyra
rook's rest had left aegon bent and
twisted
his once handsome face puffy from milk
of the poppy
with burn scars covering half his body
rhaenyra ever defiant told her dear
brother that she'd hoped he was dead
after you aegon answered
then sun fire bathed her
in a blast of flame and devoured her
in six bites when her son watched
leaving the seventh and final bite her
lower leg
for the stranger
rhaenyra was dead and king aegon
sat the iron throne again
but only for half a year he was poisoned
by his own men
and replaced with the very boy who had
watched his mother devoured
when raniere's last son wed aegon's only
daughter the dance of dragons officially
ended
passion burned men all that was left of
the riverlands
two scared children spouting oath they
didn't understand
all that was left of the mighty house
targaryen
ancient skulls and hatchlings that grew
no bigger than cats
all was left of the dragons